what I thought I'd do today is tell
about tell you a little bit about the
work that a few of us I call Sarah and
previously at Stanford have been doing
on education um I'm curious how many of
you have signed up for one of these
massive open online courses before Wow
okay okay
good I'm glad um because uh this event
is co-hosted by the Chinese faculty and
Families club um what I did today was
prepare presentation with a much
stronger international and especially
Chinese slant and so aren't you gonna
tell you about a bunch of things that
we're doing at Coursera that relate to
China specifically and some of the
trends we see taking place in China and
so this fair amount of material that I'm
gonna share today that I've actually
never presented in the United States
before we'll see how this goes so um
everything moves before most of you
already know that
Coursera today partners with top
universities including top schools in
the u.s. top schools all around the
world as well as a few non universities
teacher professional development
partners that teach teachers how to
teach in order to create free online
classes so if you visit Coursera from
the US you can get causes from visa I
think hundred-and-eight University and
other partners they have five hundred
and over five and fifty free online
courses and if you visit Coursera today
from China this is what you see and we
are very much an international website
so if you visit closer from China you
know we look like in fact we are a
Chinese website um so and and today with
over 6 million students and over 500
causes concerns by far the largest MOOC
or massive open online courses
so this is since this is Stanford I
thought I'd share of you my story of how
I guess all this had gotten started um
as a Stanford professor I used to teach
in fact I still do teach a on-campus
computer science course on machine
learning and year after year I was
reaching about 400 students in my own
campus Santa Claus it was about two and
a half years ago that I placed my class
online and I reached an audience of a
hundred thousand students so to put that
number in context for me to reach a
comparable size audience I would
otherwise have had to teach at Stanford
University for you know two hundred and
fifty years and I think what what my
team had done was created technology
that enables one professor to teach not
just a hundred or four hundred students
at the time but a hundred thousand and
that dramatically changes the economics
of higher education there is still a
large upfront costs to creating the
course ones but once you've created the
course the incremental costs of signing
up one more students is nearly zero and
that's what allows us to do this
previously crazy thing of taking courses
from the best universities around the
world and putting them online um and I
guess in the last two and a half years
we've gone from one University to 108
partners to causes that my team had
launched to over 550 and with six
million students six million students by
we're comparing Stanford University of
twenty thousand students but with six
million students Coursera today is by
far the largest massive open online
education platform in the world
so since many of you have signed up
we'll see the insides of MOOCs before
I'll be relatively brief in describing
to you what the course experience or
what the student experience is like of
taking these courses like many others
most Co several causes most most of the
causes the university partners teach
uses video based instruction so when you
sign up for one of these courses every
week you might be responsible for
watching say a couple hours of lecture
videos broken down into five to ten
minute
and over the last two years we've seen
the production quality of the videos
slowly go up we used to shoot videos
with you know like me and a webcam those
that was my first MOOC and today the
online courses you find on Coursera
often have very high production
qualities ranging from instructors doing
field work to various interviews to in
the example on the lower right hand
corner there was a Wharton you can
Wharton professor teaching a class on
gamification how to use ideas from
computer games to improve to improve
engagement of users and perhaps
appropriately to teach gamification he
chose to show up for lecture one in his
class in this persona or as his World of
Warcraft character so first day of class
instead of having the professor show up
to teach you stuff you see this you know
somewhat strange monster like feature
show up and that monster like feature
starts talking in the professor's voice
and starts to teach you about computer
games so I think this surprised by the
diversity in the creativity of them that
our instructors have been able to use in
the way to teach or video um I want to
highlight just mention about one feature
of video based instruction that makes
this a particularly efficient way to
develop to convey content to students
and that is that we support accelerated
playback of videos let me show you what
that looks like
oh please showing an example what a
lecture video looks like and the first
thing you see is the students speed up
the video to a 1.5 XP this is what that
looks like so student just sped up the
video to 1.5 X speed English captioning
useful for non-native speakers as well
as foreign language captioning written
by student volunteers um so it turns out
that one of the differences between
teaching in an online class versus
teaching in the classroom is that in on
a website on an online class often
students prefer to blast through the
material and accelerated playback
because it allows them to make more
efficient use of their time
and if they miss something they can just
go back and do an instant replay so oh
this is in contrast to a regular you
know Stanford classroom where
instructors like me will tend to just
sew things down and you know blab and
make space in order to make sure that
students are following along because
different students need different
amounts of time and if a student has
lost half way they might be lost for the
rest of the lecture um so just a great
to play back and he is the ability of
students to do instant replays allows
students I think to make much more
efficient use of their time so kind of a
personal story um it was about was it
it's about six months ago that I was
visiting LinkedIn you know here in a
over in Mountain View there was a party
at LinkedIn and one of my students came
up to me and he said you know Oh
professor my enjoy your online machine
learning class your MOOC very much
learned a lot about machine learning
taking skills using and he said to me he
said Oh presenting one of the things I'm
most liked about the cost was that I
could speed up the videos and play
everything play everything at 2xv twice
normally um and and if you missed
something if I missed something just go
back to this replay and he said really
enjoy your class but now that I have
listened to 20 hours of lecture of you
talking at 2x speed she said she said
now that I meet you in person I'm really
surprised that in person you talk so
slow
um beyond the lectures most of our
classes also have what we call Nvidia
quizzes or Nvidia polls so that rather
than passively listening to a lecture we
often pop up poll questions and pop up
quiz questions and that students do
things and interact with the material
because I think education isn't about
what the professor does is even more so
about what the student does and by
inviting students to interact on set
poll questions and reflect on their own
learning we think this is improving the
quality of their learning as well and I
think you know the again by by way of
contrast in my Stanford class when I ask
a question in my classroom you know only
one student gets to attempt an answer
right but it's on a website video stops
a question pops up like this and every
student gets to attempt an answer every
student gets feedback on the response
they just submit to the website beyond
the videos most of our courses also have
seriously CLE homeworks ranging from
short answer to math to computer
programming to sophisticated auto
grading on the lower right hand corner
is a Auto gradient spreadsheet so we can
have students build a financial model
and upload a financial model to a
website for computer to create this
model that they build um after all
Sophie my co server has been that
there's no way for a small team of us
we're about what 80 person organization
right now but there's no way for 80 the
80 of us to write all the software that
enables instructors to express their
pedagogical vision so what we've done is
develop a lot of programming interfaces
a lot of api's that enables our
university partners to plug in their
software to enable university partners
to express their pedagogical vision and
over and over up in surprise up and over
and over been blown away by the richness
of the experience that our university
partners have developed to give to their
students
in this example Rice University teaches
a computer programming course and they
developed a very sophisticated software
framework that lets students write
computer programs right there in the web
browser and by the end of the class
students in this MOOC will have finished
we have implemented for themselves
there's a asteroids like game and
students will have written for
themselves a computer game where you
know the the player flies around the
spaceship and shoots down asteroids as
was a few other games um another example
this is National Taiwan University of
Taiwan - um actually a good friend there
Benson gay who's an instructor decided
to implement himself a computer game to
encourage students to participate in the
class so Benson mr. Benson this morning
Benson developed the computer game in
which students play a board game and
have to conquer other people's
territories and the way for you to
defend your territory is to write
quizzes there's a course on probability
so to defend your territory you pose a
question on you know probability has to
be a good question and you check that
and so on and the way to attack other
people's territories is by answering
other people's quiz questions um so he
tells me that the effect of this game
was that there were you know thousands
of students that really wanted to do
well to conquer more territory and the
net effect of that was that he had
massive numbers of students healthy
obsessed with solving probability
questions they're like solving questions
day and night in order to defend their
territory and an attack of the people
stare
um and other examples from online
software to the chemical models to rich
ways for students interact with music
our a platform around programming
interfaces is I think has been key to a
strategy for allowing for helping our
university partners Express a very rich
teaching vision for how they would like
to teach so one of the nice things about
the website is that um you can grade a
student's piece of work multiple times
and a university like stand at Stanford
University when I assign the homework
usually a student gets one shot at it
because we only have the teaching
assistants to grade the homework once
and so the student gets 60 out of 100
you know they get back the graded
homework in the classrooms on with them
only partially understanding that piece
of material one of the nice things about
a website is that they have the
resources the greatest students work as
many times as they wish to submit it for
auto graded work and in fact them what
we've done is actually provide tools to
instructors to make it easy for them to
create randomized quizzes in which in
this example an instructor poses a
question with four right and four wrong
answers and each time the student comes
to the website the website automatically
generates and shows them a different set
of right and wrong answers so I think
that education shouldn't be as about
assigning grading curves education
shooting me about telling students you
know Europe B student your as a student
that's a C student I think that
education should be about helping every
student to succeed and we're Auto
grading we don't have the resources to
give every student multiple attempts at
mastering a piece of material before the
class moves on this is a teaching
technique called mastery learning
allowing students multiple opportunities
to master a piece of material and
perhaps no surprise when our university
partners and us have done studies we
could see that when a student gets
multiple attempts it allows them to have
a more firm foundation to build on and
this causes them to do better
on the next piece of material into class
as well so our data from this class
taught by EPFL EPF Lausanne in
Switzerland is that if a student gets
multiple attempts on homework for let's
say they're having a 3-point improvement
in homework 4 because they made multiple
terms translate on average into a
one-point improvement on homework 5 so
it it kind of validates this hypothesis
that giving students a more firm
foundation to build on allows them to do
better have a better shot and they two
pieces of work as well so so far I've
just talked about some computer gradient
work but not everything can be computer
graded I guess um I learned an
interesting lesson was it to spell the
year and a half girl um I think we just
developed some of this randomization
technology and I was visiting the
University of Pennsylvania in
Philadelphia and I learned that if you
walk into the office of a poetry
professor and if you show this poetry
professor you are you know shiny new
like multiple-choice alter grading
technology and if you try to convince a
poetry professor to teach his class
using only multiple-choice I learned
that he will invite you to exit his
office so to enable instructors to offer
more open-ended homeworks or we put a
lot of effort to develop a system for
peer grading the idea being that if you
want to assign an essay you know our
students to write an essay critiquing a
piece of poetry or describing an event
in history or analyzing a business case
or building a business model if you have
a hundred thousand submissions then one
professor can't grade a hundred thousand
submissions but what you can do is have
the students grade each other's work so
this idea called peer grading has
previous deepens study in small classes
and been shown to give fairly accurate
to give highly accurate raise what we
also sells was is it possible to take
this idea of peer grading previously
done onion small classes of say
these students where you have 50
students and the grade each other's work
is it possible to take this idea of peer
grading and apply it to these classes
with not fifty thousand students that
all know each other but with the hundred
thousand students that don't know each
other would that even work
so um um spent a lot of time writing
software for peer grading and so in this
example in this uh in this example in
the class on teaching strategies and
assignment on teaching was assigned to
teach us and let's see each student in
the class was asked to do a piece of
work and he stood in the class was given
guidelines for how to create other
students work and so we tried this out
about a about a year and eight months
ago year and a half ago in which we
sought to these classes where students
were write essays and five other
students total random strangers on the
Internet chosen at random we grade their
work and then we were you know take an
average of the five grades in the hope
that this would be a reasonable grade
for the student um so does it work turns
out that it does our university partners
and us have both have done multiple
studies on the efficacy or accuracy of
peer grading and were shown that having
five random strangers on the Internet
create your work and take the average if
the website that the system for doing so
is well-designed this actually results
in fairly accurate grades in fact in
certain cases not all cases but in
certain classes we believe that having
five students grade your work actually
results in more accurate grades or more
consistent grading than even having one
highly trained human Terry create the
work and then and that's because having
five people graded and take the average
actually averages out some of the random
noise that happens when the instructors
or teaching assistants when there's only
one person grading a piece of
how do you motivation is great every
student is required to create other
cities and and and and to do is you know
if you want five other people to create
your work then you have to create five
other people's work as well um so since
launching the peer grading system like a
year and eight months ago a year and a
half ago
um again as often happens we've just
repeatedly surprised by the richness of
the experience that University partners
can use our tools to give students um
these are actual homework submissions
from actual students taking a design
class taught by Wharton UPenn Wharton
and which students were asked to build a
physical artifact students were then
asked to use their cell phone cameras to
take a picture of the physical artifact
that they had built and then to upload
the picture for what they had built to
be graded by other students and over and
over we've just been repeatedly blown
away by the creativity of the
instructors in the assignments they can
offer a peer grading as well as by the
creativity and the work of the students
in the source of project that we can now
do work on and submit and get feedback
on um just one other example social
psychology um there's an instant cost
Scott Falls at Wesleyan
he usually teaches twelve students a
year on social psychology that was the
size of his class 12 students a year he
placed his constant Coursera and they
reached two hundred and forty thousand
students and for the last assignment of
his class he had a project called the
day of compassion and what he did was
ask the students to spend a day
reflecting on compassion or reflecting
on what you can do to show compassion to
others in your community and then to
write an essay describing what you did
and the winner oh and and the best
assignment the winner as voted on by
other students will receive an
invitation our expenses
trip to United States I think I hit the
Stanford I'm not sure to visit tested me
to the Dalai Lama the winner of this day
of compassion award their compassion
homework was the student called
potential ginger who is a physician that
lives near New Delhi where attacks
sexual predation on young girls is a
often a problem and what she did was she
spent a day of compassion visiting
schools and discussing this issue this
very difficult issue with young girls
near New Delhi and we believe that her
work will be a major force to educate
these young girls near New Delhi about
what is and what isn't acceptable in
terms of and to teach them to protect
themselves from sexual predation so
these are the sorts of impact that
giving tools to brilliant instructors
such as Scott plows can have on I think
on our community and on the world um
talk a lot about the student experience
talk about the lectures talked about the
homeworks the third and final third
component of student experience is the
community when you have a hundred
thousand students in the class a
community built gets built up around the
material and students come together to
discuss things with the class phase so
there's a strong sense that if you're
taking these hard classes you're not in
it alone instead you have you know
ninety nine thousand nineteen ninety
nine classmates were free to study and
to work with so I think this range of
technologies the went lectures the auto
grading peer grading discussion forums
have been key to enable us to offer a
broad range of causes there's been many
different disciplines
so let's see Coursera today so it's a
very diverse international population
from the very early days we had been
around 35% u.s. the u.s. representation
is slowly trending down as really as the
international representation slowly goes
up and just to share of you you know a
couple more stories of our students
around the world
this is Amanda who lives in a Dominica
she says concern makes study easier for
me I consider home and learn later on in
school no distractions me and my
headphones like her certificates while
spending a dime helps me a lot since my
mom is the hospital and financial cannot
afford to school or RT um devastated
left a job I'll leave you the readers
yourself and I think by taking great
causes and putting them online free for
anyone to take the impact on students is
is far larger and affects so many
students that none of us had ever
dreamed we would be able to affect to
paint a complete picture ideas of the
demographics of Caceres students today
it turns out that even though Coursera
has started with university education
really has started from two Stanford
courses the biggest effect of Coursera
today is not on college students is not
on 18 to 21 year old instead is on
continuing education and the reason for
that is that in today's world in today's
world many of us go to school go to
college for four years and then Coast on
a college education for the next 40
years and in today's rapidly changing
world that makes no sense and all of us
need regular infusions of knowledge in
order to stay current
and so um as working adults many of us
in this room I guess not counting the
standard since the GSB students but
working professionals like many of us
the northern school don't have
convenient access to continuing
education even as a Stanford professor
as challenging is challenging for me to
go sit at the back of you know Philips
classroom and it's just really awkward
because yeah and and and I think the
effect we're seeing is that the
convenience of an online class is
bringing many working professionals back
in the educational system and because of
our very international population the
seamy mention we've also put a lot of
effort into internationalizing our
website we did it first for Chinese and
then are working on what Spanish Italian
French Russian the other major world
languages right now um and because of
the very international nature of our
population were trying to
internationalize the content of the
courses as well
so today Coursera has causes taught in
English meaning the professor is
speaking English as well as courses
taught in Chinese Italian French German
Portuguese Spanish you know quite a few
languages and so university partner
Peking University or BT natashia Peking
University teachers a number of
fantastic causes for the instructor of
speaking Chinese in addition to that
were also taking courses taught by
American professor speaking English and
working with a number of translation
partners to take American content and
translate them into into other languages
as well focusing on Chinese Spanish
Russian and you know one thing that I
pursue would like to see is that I think
great teaching is to be found all over
the world by taking American content and
translating it into Chinese I hope that
University diantha can deliver more of
an education into
say China on the flip side I think that
there are also many great universities
in China and one thing I would love to
see in the future is if American
students your English speakers like
myself can access content that was
developed in Chinese so that we too can
learn from the best Chinese universities
or the best French universities I never
happened to notice a fantastic ask on
convex optimization taught in French by
Ecole Polytechnique and I wish they were
and so over time we hope to translate
this content into English as well so
that we can also learn from the best
Chinese universities the best French
universities the best Spanish
universities since there's a Chinese
audience I thought I'd mention I guess
over the last I have a what may be a
strong personal interest in China I
think visit China like six times or
something in the last year and when I
was visiting China I learned that one of
the biggest barrier to students in China
having access to cáceres and our
university partners content was just
network bandwidth network connections
and so because of that we spent a long
time what coming to agreement with
Nettie's with Wang Yi one of the large
internet sites in China the operator of
the largest free online education
resource of the largest open education
portal in China and so today most
Coursera videos are hosted in China on
net ease and we've been working with
them to increase bandwidth and increase
discoverability of our courses in China
um and finally so this is no longer on
the mobile development and one other
thing we realized was that in today's
world so much content is consumed on
mobile devices and that if frankly today
if you don't have a mobile app you know
there are large swathes of the audience
you really not reaching and so about a
month ago we released our first iOS app
and soon we will also we also plan
through these an Android app in the
future to make a content much more
accessible systems are around the world
one of the things that inspires me is
that today you can buy an inexpensive
Android tablet for something like 20 US
dollars and we have not yet released an
Android app but we plan to but what that
means is that you know for 2020 US
dollars you can now give potentially
anyone in the world access to the best
advocates to the best Caltech Casas the
best Princeton horses and I hope I think
that that will help us they'll help us
change the world
so um right since this is a GSB event as
well free online courses how do we keep
Coursera sustainable for philosophical
reasons I really wanted the causes to be
offered for free and so anyone can sign
up take a class completely in the class
for free um what we've done with many of
our university partners is offer a
program called the signature track
program in which the course is free but
we charge a modest fee for what we call
a verified certificate so the way it
works is if a student signs up for the
verified certificate we charge a modest
fee maybe 50 dollars or so and every
time they submit the homework we do some
work to verify then it really is you
sitting in your keyboard submitting the
submitting homework and I guess we use a
combination of two technologies for that
we are first ISM we use your webcam like
your laptop webcam to take a picture
with your permission to make sure it's
you sit in your keyboard and second this
builds on the old research I did at
Stanford it turns out that the way you
type on your keyboard or your typing
rhythm that's fairly unique to you this
is like a fingerprint and so every time
you submit the homework we use a
combination of your typing rhythm as
well as taking a picture with your
webcam to verify that it really is you
sit in the keyboard submitting homework
and on that basis the participating
universities and us have been issuing
verified certificates that students are
listing in their resume and then they
are frequently using successfully to
find better professional opportunities
again since this is a co-host above the
GSB I thought this would be a fun slide
to show one of the things we found was
that having students pay you know fifty
dollars to passivate the signature track
is not just a revenue strategy for us is
also a retention strategy so overall if
a student signs up for a MOOC because
enrolling is relatively easy we find
that if a student signs up for signature
track they are much more likely to
complete the class or in a certificate
um but that's no surprise if you pay $50
for the right to earn the certificate
you're more likely to actually do the
work and finish the class but here's
another interesting data point let's say
that at the start of the class we do a
survey and our students do you intend to
finish the class how committed are you
to finish the class and now let's focus
on only those students that are highly
committed to do the class your students
they'll swear up and down oh yeah
I'll do every homework all together a
long time I want to finish this so let's
just focusing on those students it turns
out that even among the highly committed
students um the ones are not on verify
segments not on signature try program
have a certain rate of completion it's
likely about 65% but those that sign up
to earn the verified certificate even
among this highly committed group has a
substantially higher about 87 percent
chance of finishing the class having
paid $40 which just goes to show that
you when you have skin in the game you
are more likely to follow through and
complete the class um one trend we're
seeing is that both students as well as
employers are increasingly taking MOOC
credentials seriously the vast majority
of students over what seventy six
percent of our students participating in
the verify service program intend to
list it in their resume and in terms of
student motivations for taking these
courses one of the students largest
motivations is to
use the credentials that they hope to
earn from these classes in order to
enhance the career either to do better
on a current career track or for a
career pivot and in order to support
students in their professional
development which is really where one of
the places cáceres doing very well now
one of the things we've done is start to
work with universities to assemble not
just single causes but to work with
university partners to try to assemble
sequences of courses one of the most
successful course sequences has been one
offered by Wharton where they took four
of the Wharton first year MBA courses
and place them online and this is one
example of where our perception was that
by taking a sequence of Wharton courses
this is one example where the whole is
more vastly more I think than the sum of
the parts and by taking sequences of
courses and earning sequences of
credentials solicited the resume
employers are increasingly taking these
credentials seriously and anecdotally
we're trying to get hard numbers but
anecdotally this is opening the doors to
many students to improved employment
opportunities so um as a machine
learning as a data scientist person one
of the things that excites me about
teaching these online courses is the
data that you can get and the learnings
that these enables when I present at
different venues
I tell different stories about what
we're doing with the data let me share
of you just one one story um so it turns
out that if every week if every week we
send you an email that says dear student
friendly reminder home workers do this
Saturday it would send you that email
you're less likely to finish the class
you're less likely to engage with the
class than that we didn't email you at
all
but on the flip side if we were to send
you an email that says dear student we
noticed you logged into the website last
week good job on that check mark oh and
we noticed you wash five videos
bujjamma and dad to check mark oh and
you got submit to the last for work on
time and you got four miles great job on
that check mark we notice also you made
a comment that was very helpful to other
students good job on that too check mark
oh and by the way the next homework is
due on Saturday if we send that email
you're much more likely to finish the
cause so perhaps it's no surprise that
if we remind you of the things you've
done well before we ask you to take the
next step that you're much more likely
to engage the class um but the way we
discovered this was not by insight the
way we discovered is was that one of my
engineers I all these designs the
different emails with different types of
content and he said let's just send tens
of thousands of these different types of
emails to tens of thousands of students
and we just look at what the students do
and we'll see what type of email
increases completion and whatever email
decreases completion and it was by
looking at the data then we went back
and actually kind of read the emails
that the guy wrote and figured out you
know after the fact that this was the
email that was more effective and down
compared to the compared to the other
and so this is a sort of lesson that we
were able to learn only because we had
tens of thousands of students that we
could send emails to randomly if
teaching you know if you're teaching one
hundred students you just cannot send
enough variations of emails in order to
get the sort of data so um at Stanford I
guess my four hundred student Stanford
class has grown to about seven hundred
and twenty or seven hundred and sixty
students so I think last quarter I told
Stanford University's largest on campus
class um but a Stanford faculty the
feedback we get from our courses is once
per year we get you know like a course
evaluation like this and that's the
feedback we get one
per year and so I feel like for the you
know decade-plus left all that Stanford
I got feedback once per year and so once
per year I get an opportunity to improve
my class and this is an incredibly slow
rate of learning for me or for my
ability to improve my class on the
website we log every mouse click every
keystroke every homework submission
correct or incorrect and the daily today
we can get from second to second or from
millisecond to millisecond is giving us
rich sources of information to feedback
to instructors that allows instructors
much more rapidly to improve their
classes and so when an instructor has a
question like should I put my face in
the lower right hand corner of the video
I don't know the answer to that we had
huge debates actually in a computer
science department when we're launching
the first few MOOCs we had huge debates
about is the instructors face just
distracting because you know it's moving
around randomly or does it help the
student form an emotional connection I
mean what is better we there were about
equal sized cams on both ends and you
won't believe how long we debated this
um but one Kosar even just get the data
and find out but 20,000 students in each
group and run what's called an a/b test
we did that so what's the answer
the answer is we still don't know or
rather the students in Group B
complained vehemently that they were
really bored and so and they really
wanted to see the instructor and so we
we cancelled that experiment but I guess
that actually told us in this case
they're having the instructors face is
more more efficient and these are the
experiments that our instructors are
engineers routinely run today there are
I would guess hi dozens of a B tests
running on Coursera right now most of
which I don't even know about and a
rapid speed of running tests getting
feedback is allowing us to improve
learning at a rate that I personally had
never before experienced when I was
and because of that - we put a lot of
effort into developing instructor
interfaces to take the data from the
classes and feed information about their
classes back to the instructors so that
they can get these signals and this has
been a major investment for us to make
the data to make the raw data available
to the universities if they choose to
analyze it as well as to take the
results of our analyses our instructor
interfaces and feed this information all
back to the UM to the to the instructors
and and yeah I guess maybe kind of find
a sense of just being since since that
I've mentioned the the cat thing in my
former life I ran a team out of Google
that built one of Google's largest
machine learning systems I'll serve
today if any of you use an Android cell
phone speech recognition on every
Android cell phone in the United
actually in the world except for China
runs on top of software that that my
team at Google had built um but one
things I learned there was also if you
think about your advertising right why
why are certain types of ads why display
ads brand advertising less valuable it's
just because if I show you you know like
a Gucci brand and you don't click on it
I don't get information back and so you
can't optimize the app so the ability to
feed information back to you so that you
can optimize something makes that much
more valuable this is the ability your
ability to get data to let you optimize
make something much more valuable and we
hope to do that with education um maybe
just to finish up one one last piece
into Stanford you know over the last
about two years I've often been asked if
anyone can go online and take you know
free stanford classes why on earth would
anyone still very travel to united
states and come to Stanford - erm
Stanford degree and I think the answer
is that the real value of a Stanford
education isn't just the content content
is increasingly free on the web anyway
frankly whether we like it or not and I
think in my opinion the reason students
come to the great universities Stanford
Princeton couch
or Peking University or Fudan University
on Shelton University students come to
our great campuses not just on the
content but for the interactions of the
professors and the interactions with
other equally priced students so I like
this quote by foo talk that the mind is
not a vessel then he's fooling but with
the knees igniting and I think our role
as instructors is not to fill minds I
think it is to ignite minds so many of
our university partners are now
implementing what's called the flip to
pass through mode of instruction in
which by putting the lecture content on
Coursera they can send their students on
to the website to watch the videos on
the website and what does does is it
preserves the classroom time for the
instructor to deliver higher value for
the instructor to move up the value
chain and to deliver higher value
services such as real mentoring coaching
to work with students on research um for
university perspective one other
fascinating use of MOOCs has been that
at most universities we have a teaching
mission as well as a research mission
and both are incredibly important to our
universities the impact on the teaching
mission I think is clear through use of
the flipped classroom to improve the
quality of on-campus teaching what was
signed to see is an impact on our
University's research mission as well so
if a student joins the Stanford computer
science department and wants to work
with me say on research often they have
to wait a year until my machine learning
causes off of the game then take two and
a half months to take the class and then
after that and you know after that maybe
fifty weeks or something they have quite
the knowledge they need in order to be
productive in doing research in my group
but now that I have so much more content
online what I can do
what I do do is send Stanford students
to take a two-week intensive period to
learn as much as they can to learn
everything I need them to know about
machine learning and so after two weeks
we can now get new stand I've been able
to get new Stanford students to be
productive and
rather than you know like a 50 week
cycle until the right cost comes along
in the tickle calls and so on and so I
think that especially as content becomes
more modular having online contents what
we are being able to allow great
universities and has not just a teaching
mission but also their research mission
by allowing us to much more efficiently
give our students undergrad and grad
students the skills they need in order
to engage with what research in our
communities um most of that so just to
wrap up um you know here's something
they'd like to see happen in in in in in
a year or two I hope that um in a year
I hope that there'll be a lower-income
individual maybe I check out clerk
working for Safeway I hope that they
were lower income individual maybe right
here in California or maybe in the
developing economy who I hope that
there'll be such a person they'll sign
up to take a dozen Coursera movers they
have to work really hard to finish these
courses but I hope that that person will
list the courses on the resume and use
it to find a better job and earn a
livelihood for themselves and the family
because if we can offer that to the
Safeway checkout clerk that wants a
better life for their family or to a
struggling adult in India who's earning
a degree that does not offer him
realistic employment opportunities if we
can use technology as scale to offer
such a person a shot at a better life
what that means is that we can use
technology and skill to give everyone a
shot at the middle class and I think
this country needs it I think other
countries probably need it even more but
I think that if we can give everyone on
this planet
a shot to the middle class I think we
can dramatically and has the progress of
a civilization and give so many more
people and the families a vastly
improved life and with that let me say
thank you very much